maybe a show on Thursday calm down I
don't show on Thursday at 3:00 on Friday
if you're feeling froggy what oh you
can't do three ought to throw your older
I'll do three and four and one day in
Dublin oh you oh you learn one day you
can't do three hey can I be honest with
you all [ __ ] aside where's the love
you're a big strong athlete yes sir I
have more endurance than you right no
papa you get old down oh you're back
everything breaks down
oh we're doing fine kids bed I was a pop
dude listen you mean your brother's more
show you and your brothers listen I do
more shows no no you don't say that I'll
beat you up last year no it doesn't
matter if you never listen well over
over a lifetime no no no no no right now
it's a fan sorry I broke you down bubble
me and your brother are a couple of
night hours right a couple of vampires
we stay up you that's different that's
doing you got away well I don't like
people you're bait you [ __ ] go on my
back and then you break down I've been
with my shut it down like you got my
[ __ ] lower back I can't move and then
you have to waddle to my doll I see you
like bars though you do to 9:30 you is
not true you can't hurt big dogs get
tired it's alright because it's a fire
like but Papa I'm gonna do four [ __ ]
I'll do I'll do three shout there you go
see three 100% free for too much too
much for you not so much it gets like
sports a lot buy for you feel sick yes
by that fourth show you feel sick your
stuff 100% I'll do three on Friday
another one have we sold 700 taken
Spokane already yet you think that and
there's a lot there say mercy and
they're foaming at the mouth that
foaming it they're foaming at the dick I
can't wait comedy
I can't wait we're gonna add Salt Lake I
think July 17 18 you how's that gonna be
the first thick boy by club festival
yeah it is Salt Lake City so we'll do
Salt Lake bring your stupid old ass how
many how many shows we do why don't we
do more than just two days I'm trying to
add the third day and do three shows
every day okay Wow
what that can I just say one thing about
that that's high altitude Bubba high
altitude Oh old fun I don't want you I
don't want you alright then in the high
altitude I don't want you to really
adapt you know what you do have good
alerts yeah you always have did your
opponent so I wonder if that's from
living in Denver for real they say if
you're born in high altitude you do have
do you say that
yeah nobody because you do have very
good cardio for a giant we'll see who
lasts long at a bike if you want or we
can run you want to run is back are you
there only I think I could beat you in
all those the problem is my feet my
[ __ ] ass I have three problems my god
me too papa
you want to try it I don't want to go
endurance with me even at 53 you just
don't even in jujitsu you know what the
joke was do you want to go again Bryan I
never got tired never just give cantata
no I didn't get to keep contender I
didn't get easy what I didn't get tapped
out this is your hardest work that's not
true when I was training training my
salt you didn't see it I've seen you
trade multiple when I was stopping to
chip do when I stopped doing jiu-jitsu
it's my pressure of Ruben this is my
impression of Bryan he's taking a [ __ ]
it's my impression of Bryan and
jiu-jitsu gym that's fellas let's do it
again
and they're like dude we're exhausted
tapping up come on more time yeah you
saw me wrestle with Jake Shields and all
you monsters no just regular people know
you've never seen me roll with regular
people this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]